hey 42 here as far as eccentric
billionaires go alabama-based
george w barber is high up on the list
he owns the world's largest motorcycle
collection and his own private racetrack
but when you pick those off your list
what else you do with your endless money
well in the 90s barber uses wealth to
have a handful of life-sized dinosaurs
built and placed randomly around the
10,000 acre woodlands surrounding his
home the dinosaurs are also accompanied
by a collection of medieval knight
statues because why the hell not
but he didn't stop there barber also
commissioned a life-sized fiberglass
replica of stonehenge that he
hilariously named bomber heads and to
top it all off a 50-foot naked woman
submerged in his private marina so
despite the fact that have you become a
billionaire you'll have vastly more
money than you'll know what to do with
and you'll have to resort to building
giant dinosaurs and women the desire to
be one is great let's not lie to
ourselves most people would love to be a
billionaire even if we don't know why or
how we would even spend our fortune but
the unlucky reality is that your chances
of a mussing 1 billion dollars or pounds
worth of assets within your lifetime are
pitifully slim the current population is
7.5 billion people and there are 2043
billionaires in the world today meaning
the chance of you becoming a billionaire
is just zero point zero zero zero zero
to seven percent so should you just give
up now
no because you can of course increase
your chances of becoming a billionaire
you see billionaires aren't like you and
I their behaviors and actions are very
different and unusual and sometimes
Verge
on criminal and sadistic show that
copying these behaviors won't guarantee
that you'll become a billionaire but it
will vastly increase your chances
firstly they are very patient far more
patients than the average person
billionaire investor Warren Buffett once
said the stock market is a device for
transferring money from the impatience
to the patient most people want success
overnight and it's easy to feel like
you've failed if you don't achieve it
and one's natural instinct is to beat
yourself up over failure or just slow
growth but patience is the key to
success the world's wealthiest
individuals are no strangers to failure
and having to wait sometimes decades for
success to come along due to their hard
efforts Bill Gates the richest person on
the planet as far as we know anyway
knows this all too well you've heard of
Microsoft but have you heard of truffaut
data no that's because it was a huge
flop truffaut data was mr. Gates's first
company its goal was to read the raw
data from roadway traffic counters and
create reports for traffic engineers
gates thought that his genius idea would
optimize traffic and end whoa congestion
forever but the technology didn't work
and it fell flat on its face book gates
had patience and perseverance and from
the ashes of truffaut data Microsoft was
born since then Microsoft has created
three billionaires and over 12,000
millionaires
james dyson created an incredible 5127
vacuum prototypes over 15 years before
he finally took his first bagless vacuum
to market Thomas Edison famously said I
have not failed I've just found 10,000
ways that won't work from Steve Jobs to
Richard Branson they all had to fail
miserably before they found success if
they had been impatient they may have
thrown in the towel and achieved not
billionaires are the world's best
problem solvers to solving problems is
how most of them made their fortunes but
the road to riches is often fraught with
seemingly impossible obstacles when
Joseph pescado was starting up his
software company pants avec it was going
fantastically well for a few years with
two hundred and thirty million dollars
of annual revenue until one New Year's
Eve in 1985 a disgruntled ex-employee
walked through the company's data center
with an industrial-strength
electromagnet erasing every single hard
drive in the building this was a
complete disaster
they have no external bucket and
everyone thought the company will close
its doors for good but a defiant Piscopo
set to work on rebuilding all the lost
data within just two weeks the data was
restored and the company was flourishing
again and then there's Rock Mackay
founder of a billion-dollar cancer
treatment company called tomotherapy
he encountered an entrepreneurs worst
nightmare right at the launch of his
company the main investor pulled out on
launch day and Mackey had to fire all of
his employees on the spot yet despite
the incredible odds against him Mackey
still managed to go public with
tomotherapy from a billion dollar
valuation they were also small everyday
behaviors of most billionaires share
they are all very early risers for
example Apple CEO Tim Cook General
Motors CEO Dan Akerson and Disney CEO
Robert Iger have all reported that they
wake up at 4:30 every morning and
according to research the vast majority
of billionaires are awake by at least
5:30 a.m. our brains are at our best in
the morning and without distractions of
other people and family obligations it's
amazing but one could accomplish in just
one day
new york-based Billina Owen Simon wakes
up at 5:00 a.m. and he says that he
accomplishes more before 9 a.m.
now most people do all day he spends the
early hours of the morning answering
emails calling and managing his
operations in Europe and Asia he prays
walk the dog and exercises all before
his kids even wake up Owen he even has
time to sit down for breakfast in
Manhattan before arriving at his office
to start his actual workday what surely
of all these billionaires are waking up
so early they must be going to bed
ridiculously early to know quite the
opposite these individuals have the rare
ability to function at maximum capacity
on very little sleep a study identified
a small group of people roughly 2% of
the population and consumption and live
very happily on very little sleep just a
few hours each night in fact this isn't
just willpower either researchers
actually found that these people carry a
mutation of a gene called hate Dec 2
when they tweaked the same gene and put
it into mice they found that the mice
began to sleep less just like the human
test subjects this is therefore a
biological gift for the lucky 2% that
have been named the sleepless elite and
what's even more amazing is that these
same people tend to be very highly
successful many millionaires
billionaires prime ministers and
presidents have been found to possess
the gift of not needing much sleep
Thomas Jefferson Benjamin Franklin and
Leonardo da Vinci are just a few people
who were known to have this unusual gift
although there are some very successful
people who didn't have this gift yet
they actually forced themselves to sleep
less so that they could get more done
Margaret Thatcher trained herself to
only sleep for four hours every single
night I can easier sympathize with
Winston Churchill oh he begrudged
getting out of bed so much that he would
spend the entire morning
came from his bed and even received
important visitors in his bedroom but if
we put these smaller attributes of
billionaires aside there's one major
glaring trait that you absolutely must
have to become very very wealthy to
control such a large portion of the
world's wealth you have to be a total
psychopath or at the very least a
sociopath and I'm not being sycophantic
most billionaires are clinical
Psychopaths some will kill is an
economist and head of Business Research
at Oxford Economics he has long studied
and also wrote a book about the world's
wealthiest 1% and the common factor that
they share and in all of his time
studying hundreds of wealthy tycoons he
discovered one common factor they are
willing to do absolutely anything to
gain market monopoly and ruthlessly for
second Pettit earth into the ground I'm
not saying that all billionaires are
serial killers but like serial killers
most are unable to feel empathy this
helps them to make difficult decisions
that may harm others but will advance
their own goals criminal psychologist
Robert hare famously discovered through
his research that 1% of the general
population are categorized as
Psychopaths however over 10% of
financial traders stock brokers and
bankers are psychopaths being a
psychopath doesn't mean you're going to
Massacre your own family with a chainsaw
psychopathy is simply a condition that
is quite easily diagnosed by having the
following traits superficially charming
highly manipulative unable to con offers
a complete lack of empathy or remorse
and a willingness to take large risks so
I basically just described Donald Trump
and probably any of a billionaire you
can think of but perhaps there's a
reason that billionaires are psychic
because it is what is required to make
it to the top in this crazily
competitive capitalist society only
those who are willing to take large risk
and skirt around the edges of the law
perhaps even breaking them from time to
time are going to gain that competitive
edge needed to obliterate the
competition and monopolize a market
think Facebook YouTube Google Amazon
they are so wildly successful and able
to grow with astonishing velocity
because they have no effective
competitors and that's the way they like
it has long been rumored that Bill Gates
stole the idea of Windows from his Apple
colleagues Warren Buffett pays income
tax on only 0.01 8% of his 70 4.2
billion dollars worth of assets whilst
the rest of us are paying between 25 and
60% tax and then there are the
billionaires that made their wealth from
poisoning the waters with nuclear waste
all the South American drug barons those
who've got wealthy and Blood Diamond and
of course the billionaires who made
their wealth building and selling arms
used to slaughter millions of innocent
people to do these things about feeling
any remorse want have to have a degree
of psychopathy about them this doesn't
mean that all billionaires are bad
people quite the opposite but there is
undeniably a certain mega manic quality
and a specific set of attributes
required to amass vast sums of wealth
but of course the best way to increase
your chances of becoming a billionaire
is not by studying and copying of a
billionaire behaviors but by getting out
there and putting your every fiber into
whatever you're passionate about because
success comes to those who are too busy
to be looking for it thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video then please
click here to support me on patreon
not only will you help me to make better
videos but you'll also get some cool
rewards like t-shirts and posters every
month and early access to all my videos
click here to watch another video and if
you haven't already don't forget to
subscribe